[Applause]
thousands of people risk their safety to
attend this government organized rally
in Mogadishu against al-shabab
Somali president Hassan Sheikh Muhammad
has been ramping up support for what he
calls an all-out war against the armed
group
now his urging somalis to report
Fighters living among them
if you see someone you don't know in
your neighborhood please ask him who are
you if you can't ask him please call us
and tell us that there's an unknown
person in your neighborhood then we will
ask him what are you doing where did you
come from nothing wrong with that it's
not as if you're bothering your
neighbors
has carried out attacks in Somalia and
across East Africa since it emerged in
2007. more than 4 000 people have been
killed most of them in Somalia the
government says it will support
communities that expose al-shabab
hideouts residents of mogadisha are not
safe any day at any minute at any given
time so I think it's it's about time
that the citizens actually rise up and
claim their own security back by the
government and and we are seeing across
the country at Groundswell against
Shabad somalia's military and local
armed groups have retaken sways of
territory in central parts of the
country in recent months the operation
is backed by U.S airstrikes and African
Union forces
but the group retaliated in November
Fighters stormed a hotel in Mogadishu
The Siege lasted nearly a day and
hundreds of people were killed in Twin
bombings at the end of October many
somalis have had enough
we have to report anyone who we suspect
to be a member of al-shabaab to the
authorities because they will kill
innocent people
a recent report by the international
crisis group says al-shabab has reduced
Recruitment and some foreign Fighters
are leaving the group the government
says local support is essential for
recent gains to continue Barbara angopa
Al Jazeera